n'est-il pas après tout un phénomène
social
après une longue période d'oubli le
scooby doo est revenu à la mode on le
pratique à tout âge on lui donne toutes
les formes et on le destine à de
multiples usages alors cela méritait de
notre part un dossier et c'est rené
raynaud qui s'est chargé de cette étude
[Musique]
ce ne sont que des fils multicolores
enchevêtrées encore faut-il savoir les
enchevêtrées c'est la technique
encore faut-il savoir choisir les tons
et composé les enchevêtrements alors
cela confine à l'art modeste apprenti ou
déjà grands artistes les jeunes sont
depuis quelques semaines saisie d'un
bout à l'autre de l'hexagone d'une
fièvre créatrice scooby doo est le
languedoc-roussillon concours largement
à cet effort national
un exemple parmi des milliers d'autres
nous a été donnée à nîmes au collège
condorcet j'ai donné à voir un discours
dans le collège parce que y'a après moi
j'en ai vu chez
le libraire j'en ai fait d'un d'alcool
et la diversité de la création entraîné
l'apparition de véritables bourse aux
échanges
comment je me lavais l'avion je crois la
violer a comme toutes les modes
le scooby doo à ses retombées
économiques
un fils ça coûte 50 centimes et le brun
enfin le scooby doo
ça coûte de frein dans ses quatre fils
[Musique]
mais à ce que v de v vient d'arriver
depuis un mois environ que nous avons
cette vente de scooby doo qui fait
courir tous tout aux nîmois ses volets
fin et par mail aux 2000 ou 3000 ou 4000
par josse un fil au niveau à
témoignage de sa vitalité le scooby doo
doit aussi affronter déjà la
contestation
je dis que je suis contre les scoubidous
parce que c'est une mode et je suis
contre toutes les modes
ça coûte qu'elle fera france et le prix
d'une baguette a alors il ya des gens
qui ont des difficultés à vivre même
dans la zup là il suffit pas cherché à
penser qu'il ouvre un fouet et déjà
qu'ils ont passé le manger avant jeudi
élevage privé acheter des scoubidous
prévu les données regroupées pour le
tiers-monde commencer je fais pas parce
que je les soutiens qu'il y est ou non
polémique force est de constater que les
jeunes ne sont pas seuls à scooby d1
cela signifie
celui-là je vais faire avec 14 ans
filles se décale jt je suis là comme la
mode est revenu je me suis remis à me
faire un peu bas
à sauver des vies
[Musique]